In Venezuela, military commanders across the nation...
...are vowing loyalty to embattled President Nicolas Maduro,...
...as violence flares in anti-government demonstrations supporting Juan Guaido.
In the Democratic Republic of Congo, Felix Tshisekedi is sworn in as president...
...in the country's first peaceful transition of power.
The results were delayed three times,...
...with Tshisekedi ultimately winning by a 3.7 percent margin.
In Sudan, police officers fire tear gas at hundreds of anti-government protesters...
...trying to march on the presidential palace in Khartoum...
...and pressure President Omar al-Bashir to resign.
The Foreign Ministry in Pakistan confirms...
...that negotiations between the Taliban and US officials in Qatar are ongoing,...
...as the two sides pursue a potential deal to end Afghanistan's 17-year conflict.
Finally from Israel, a court has seized a Jerusalem property...
...partly owned by the late Palestinian leader Yasser Arafat,...
...holding it as collateral against a civil suit...
...for damages by the Palestinian Authority.